[música]
hace sus palabras
Hermano
objetivos
[música]
por supuesto que podemos y seremos nuestras autoridades
dar armas nosotros las llevaremos y
protege tu radio, bueno al menos
estaremos al principio
usa los oídos que tenemos
nosotros en qué tablero estaremos
disfruta pero 1 minuto antes lo haremos
parte y defiende nuestra ciudad
[música]
o quedarse no trabajará en sí misma
página de conocimiento unificado y
Puse el centro pero todavía hay
Dios puso tengo mas de ti y salud
y salud para vivir se alegran
personal
visto hasta el sujeto espantapájaros zona arriba
ataúd y dejar un poco de whisky y conocimiento y
nosotros habilidades y
[música]
no habrá tal cosa pero nadie allí a la vista
personas entrenadas en no atraidas
para que despiertes toda la misma adrenalina y yo
Yakos pánico todos los mismos suplementos dietéticos y un quiste sería
todo y
aquí estamos en el chat sexo y dulat y shvydkogo y
toque el par sit y cs y off también
hacha mente lydia nosotros hora
[música]
Y